und damit gehen wir über live in den
bundestag in wenigen minuten sekunden
kann man schon sagen die
regierungserklärung von bundeskanzler
und
hier wird jetzt begrüßt der ukrainische
botschafter andrej melik mit großem
applaus er hat der bundesregierung gehen
den vergangenen tagen und wochen heftige
vorwürfe gemacht hat ihr auch hierbei
bild verrat unter anderem vorgeworfen
und nimmt jetzt teil an dieser so
wichtigen sitzung auch für sein land
natürlich seine forderungen solche
zumindest ansatzweise umgesetzt werden
von deutschland also auch deutsche
waffen geliefert werden an sein land an
die ukraine und dieser lange lange
applaus standing ovations dort leben
joachim erlaubte ihm jetzt auch noch mal
die hand schüttelt und die beiden
umarmen sich der bundespräsident das
natürlich auch dort im bundestag ein
zeichen der solidarität mit der kabine
jetzt wird platzeck in gedanken sind wir
bei ihren landsleuten die in diesen
tagen die freiheit und die demokratie
verteidigen
am freitagabend habe ich in einem
telefonat mit meinem amtskollegen
russland stefan tschök allen mitgliedern
des ukrainischen parlaments und allen
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer unsere hilfe
und unterstützung angeboten
der deutsche bundestag und die menschen
in unserem land stehen fest an ihrer
seite
an der seite der freien und
demokratischen
ukraine
wir konnten diesen krieg kommen sehen
verhindern konnten wir ihn nicht es ist
schmerzhaft sich das eingestehen zu
müssen
dennoch war es richtig es auf allen
diplomatischen kanälen versucht zu haben
denn jeder krieg kennt nur verlierer
hunderte menschen sind bereit sind den
kämpfen getötet worden mehr als 100.000
sind auf der flucht unser mitgefühl gilt
allen angehörigen
die menschen verloren haben und von leid
und zerstörung betroffen sind es kommt
jetzt darauf an gleichermaßen besonnen
und entschlossen zu handeln
im bündnis der demokratischen staaten
ich danke ihnen allen dass sie gekommen
sind der deutsche bundestag kommt heute
an einem sonntag zu einer sondersitzung
zusammen in dieser historischen
ausnahmesituation
ist es auch ein wichtiges signal der
solidarität unseres gesamten hauses
der bundeskanzler wird gleich eine
regierungserklärung abgeben auf sein
verlangen gemäß artikel
39 absatz 3 des grundgesetzes in
verbindung mit § 21 absatz 2 unserer
geschäftsordnung habe ich die heutige
sondersitzung
einberufen
damit komme ich jetzt auch zu
tagesordnungspunkt 1 abgabe einer
regierungserklärung durch den
bundeskanzler zur aktuellen lage hierzu
liegen mehrere entschließungsanträge vor
nach einer interfraktionellen
vereinbarungen sind für die ansprache im
anschluss an die regierungserklärung
150 minuten vorgesehen ich höre kein
widerspruch dann ist das so beschlossen
das wort zur abgabe einer
regierungserklärung hat der
bundeskanzler herr olaf scholz
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin werte
kolleginnen und kollegen liebe
mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger
der 24 februar
2022 markiert eine zeitenwende in der
geschichte unseres kontinents mit dem
überfall auf die ukraine hat der
russische präsident putin kaltblütig
einen angriffskrieg vom zaun gebrochen
aus einem einzigen grund die freiheit
der ukrainerinnen und ukrainer stellt
sein eigenes unterdrückungsregime in
frage das ist menschenverachtend es ist
völkerrechtswidrig dass es durch nichts
und niemanden zu rechtfertigen
die schrecklichen bilder aus kiew odessa
und mario pohl zeigt die ganze
skrupellosigkeit potenz die
himmelschreiende ungerechtigkeit
der schmerz der ukrainerin ukraine sie
gehen uns allen sehr nahe
ich weiß genau
welche fragen sich die bürgerinnen und
bürger in diesen tagen abends am
küchentisch der welche sorgen sie
umtreiben
angesichts der furchtbaren nachrichten
aus dem krieg
viele von uns haben noch die erzählung
unserer eltern oder großeltern immer vom
krieg
und für die jüngeren ist es kaum fassbar
krieg in europa
viele von ihnen verleihen ihrem
entsetzen ausdruck überall im land hier
in berlin
wir erleben eine zeitenwende
und das bedeutet die welt danach
ist nicht mehr dieselbe wie die welt
davor
im kern geht es um die frage ob macht
das recht brechen darf ob wir es putin
gestatten die uhren zurückzudrehen in
die zeit der großmächte des neunzehnten
jahrhunderts oder ob wir die kraft
aufbringen kriegstreibern wie putin
grenzen zu setzen
das setzt eigene stärke voraus
ja wir wollen und wir werden unsere
freiheit unsere demokratie und unseren
wohlstand sichern und ich bin ihnen frau
präsidentin sehr dankbar dass sich die
vorstellung der bundesregierung dazu
heute in dieser sondersitzung mit dem
teilen kann und auch den vorsitzenden
aller demokratischen fraktionen dieses
hauses danke ich dafür dass sie diese
sitzung unterstützt
meine damen und herren mit dem überfall
auf die ukraine will putin nicht nur ein
unabhängiges land von der weltkarte
tilgen er zertrümmert die europäische
sicherheits ordnung wie sie seit der
schlussakte von helsinki
fast ein halbes jahrhundert bestand
hatte er stellt sich auch ins abseits
der gesamten internationalen
staatengemeinschaft
weltweit haben unsere botschaften in den
vergangenen tagen gemeinsam mit
frankreich dafür geworben die russische
aggression im sicherheitsrat der
vereinten nationen als das zu benennen
was sie ist ein infamer völkerrechts
bruch
und wenn man sich das ergebnis der
sicherheitsratssitzung in new york
anschaut durchaus mit erfolg die
beratung haben gezeigt wir stehen
keineswegs allein in unserem einsatz für
den frieden wir werden den fortsetzen
mit aller kraft dafür was sie dort
zustande gebracht hat bin ich aus
minister in bernburg sehr dankbar
[Applaus]
nur mit der notbremse seines vetos
konnte moskau immerhin ein ständiges
mitglied des sicherheitsrates die eigene
verurteilung verhindern was für eine
schande
präsident putin redet dabei stets von
unteilbaren sicherheit
tatsächlich aber will er gerade den
kontinent mit waffengewalt in
altbekannte einflusssphären teilen
das hat folgen für die sicherheit in
europa
dauerhaft ist sicherheit in europa nicht
gegen russland möglich auf absehbare
zeit aber gefährte putin diese
sicherheit das muss klar ausgesprochen
werden
wir nehmen die herausforderung an vor
der die zeit uns gestellt hat nüchtern
und entschlossen
fünf handlungs aufträge liegen nun vor
uns
erstens wir müssen die ukraine in dieser
verzweifelten lage unterstützen das
haben wir auch in den vergangenen wochen
monaten und jahren in großem umfang
getan aber mit dem überfall auf die
ukraine sind wir in einer neuen zeit in
kiew
odessa und mario pohl verteidigen die
menschen nicht nur ihre heimat sie
kämpfen für freiheit und ihre demokratie
für werte die mit ihm teilen
als demokratinnen und demokraten als
europäerinnen und europäer stehen wir an
ihrer seite auf der richtigen seite der
geschichte
am donnerstag hat präsident putin mit
seinem überfall auf die ukraine eine
neue realität geschaffen
diese neue realität erfordert eine klare
antwort wir haben sie gegeben wie sie
wissen haben wir gestern entschieden
dass deutschland der ukraine waffen zur
verteidigung des landes liefern wird
auf gut ins aggression konnte es keine
andere antwort geben
meine damen und herren unser zweiter
handlungsauftrag ist putin von seinem
kriegsbuch kurs abzubringen der krieg
ist eine katastrophe für die ukraine
aber der krieg wird sich auch als
katastrophe für russland erweisen
gemeinsam mit den eu und staats und
regierungschefs haben wir ein
sanktionspaket von bisher unbekannten
ausmaß verabschiedet wir schneiden
russische bank und staatsunternehmen von
der finanzierung haben wir verhindern
den export von zukunfts technologie nach
russland
wir nehmen die oligarchen und ihre
geldanlagen in der eu ins visier hinzu
kommen die strafmaßnahmen gegen putin
und personen in seinem direkten umfeld
und einschränkungen bei der visavergabe
für russische offizielle
und wir schließen wichtige russische
banken von banken kommunikationsnetz
swift aus darauf haben wir uns gestern
mit dem staats und regierungschefs
vertreten
machen wir uns nichts vor
putin wird seinen kurs nicht über nacht
ändern
doch schon sehr bald wird die russische
führung spüren welchen preis sie bezahlt
allein in der letzten woche haben
russische börsenwert um über 30 prozent
nachgegeben das zeigt unsere sanktionen
wirken und wir behalten uns weitere
sanktionen vor ohne irgendwelche
denkverbote
unsere richtschnur bleibt die frage was
trifft die verantwortlichen am härtesten
die um die es geht und nicht das
russische volk
wenn putin nicht das russische volk hat
sich für den krieg entschieden
deshalb gehört es deutlich ausgesprochen
dieser krieg ist putins krieg
die differenzierung ist mir wichtig
denn die aussöhnung zwischen deutschen
und russen nach dem zweiten weltkrieg
ist und bleibt ein wichtiges kapitel
unserer gemeinsamen geschichte
und ich weiß wie schwierig zu ertragen
die derzeitige situation gerade für die
vielen bürgerinnen und bürger unseres
landes ist die in der ukraine oder in
russland geboren sind
darum werden wir nicht zulassen dass
dieser konflikt zwischen putin und der
freien welt zum aufreißen alter wunden
und zu neuen verwerfungen führt
und noch etwas sollten wir nicht
vergessen in vielen russischen städten
haben bürgerinnen und bürger in den
vergangenen tagen gegen putins krieg
protestiert haben verhaftung und
bestrafung in kauf genommen das
erfordert großen
deutschland steht heute an der seite der
ukraine ukraine unsere gedanken und
unser mitgefühl gelten heute den opfern
des russischen angriffskriegs
und genau so stehen der an der seite all
jener in russland die putins
machtapparat mutig die stirn bieten und
seinen krieg gegen die ukraine ablehnen
wir wissen sie sind viele
ihnen allen sage ich geben sie nicht auf
ich bin ganz sicher
freiheit toleranz und menschenrechte
werden sich auch in russland durchsetzen
meine damen und herren die dritte große
herausforderung liegt darin zu
verhindern dass putins krieg auf andere
länder in europa übergreift das bedeutet
ohne wenn und aber stehen wir zu unserer
beistandspflicht in der nato
das habe ich auch unseren alliierten in
mittel und osteuropa gesagt die sich um
ihre sicherheit sorgen
präsident putin sollte unsere
entschlossenheit nicht unterschätzen
gemeinsam mit unseren alliierten jeden
quadratmeter des bündnisgebietes zu
verteidigen
wir meinen das sehr ernst mit der
aufnahme eines landes in die nato ist
unser wille als bündnispartner verbunden
dieses land zu verteidigen und zwar so
wie uns selbst
die bundeswehr hatte ihre unterstützung
für die östlichen bündnispartner bereits
ausgeweitet und wird das weiter tun für
dieses wichtige signal danke ich der
bundesverteidigungsministerium in
litauen wo wir den einsatz verband der
nato führen haben wir unsere truppe
aufgestockt und sein einsatz beim r
police in rumänien haben wir verlängert
und ausgeweitet
wir wollen uns am aufbau einer neuen
nato einheit in der slowakei beteiligt
unsere marine hilft mit zusätzlichen
schiffen bei der sicherung von nord und
ostsee und im mittelmeer und wir sind
bereit uns mit luftabwehrraketen auch an
der verteidigung des luftraums unserer
alliierten in osteuropa zu beteiligen
unsere soldatinnen und soldaten haben in
den vergangenen tagen oft nur wenig zeit
gehabt sich auf diese einsätze
vorzubereiten ich sage ihnen und sicher
auch in ihrem namen danke
[Applaus]
danke und für ihren wichtigen dienst
gerade in diesen tagen
meine damen und herren angesichts der
zeitenwende die putins aggression
bedeutet lautet unser maßstab was für
die sicherung des friedens in europa
gebraucht wird das wird getan
deutschland tritt dazu seinen
solidarischen beitrag leisten
dass heute klar und unmissverständlich
fest zu halten reicht aber nicht aus
denn dafür braucht die bundeswehr neue
starke fähigkeiten
und das ist mein viertes anliegen
und das ist mein viertes anliegen meine
damen und herren
er putins historisierende abhandlung
liest
wer seine öffentliche kriegserklärung an
die ukraine im fernsehen gesehen hat
oder wer wie ich kürzlich persönlich mit
ihm stundenlang gesprochen hat der kann
kein zweifel mehr haben
putin will ein russisches imperium
richten
will die verhältnisse in europa nach
seinen vorstellungen grundlegend neu
ordnen und dabei schreckt er nicht
zurück vor militärischer gewalt das
sehen wir heute in der ukraine
wir müssen uns daher fragen welche
fähigkeiten besitzt putins russland
und welche fähigkeiten brauchen wir um
dieser bedrohung zu begegnen heute und
in der zukunft
[Applaus]
klar ist wir müssen deutlich mehr
investieren in die sicherheit unseres
landes um auf diese weise unsere
freiheit und unsere demokratie zu
schützen
das ist eine große nationale
kraftanstrengung
das ziel ist eine leistungsfähige
hochmoderne fortschrittliche bundeswehr
die uns zuverlässig schützt
ich habe bei der münchner
sicherheitskonferenz vor einer woche
gesagt wir brauchen flugzeuge die
fliegen schiffe die in see stechen und
soldatinnen soldaten die für ihre
einsätze optimal ausgerüstet sind
darum geht es
und das ist ja wohl erreichbar für ein
land unserer größe und unserer bedeutung
in europa
aber machen wir uns nichts vor bessere
ausrüstung modernes einsatzgerät mehr
personal das kostet viel geld
wir werden dafür
ein sondervermögen bundeswehr einrichten
und ich bin bundesfinanzminister lindner
sehr dankbar für seine unterstützung
dabei
der bundeshaushalt
2022 wird dieses sondervermögen einmalig
mit 100 milliarden euro ausstatten die
mittel werden der für notwendige
investitionen rüstungsvorhaben noch
wir werden von nun an jahr für jahr mehr
als zwei prozent des
bruttoinlandsprodukts und unsere
verteidigung bisher
und
und meine damen und herren
ich richte mich hier an alle fraktionen
des deutschen bundestages
lassen sie uns das sondervermögen im
grundgesetz absichern
eines will ich hinzufügen
wir streben dieses ziel nicht nur an
weil wir bei unseren freunden oder
alliierten im wort stehen unsere
verteidigungsausgaben bis 2024 auf zwei
prozent unserer wirtschaftsleistung zu
steigern
wir tun dies auch für uns für unsere
eigene sicherheit
wohl wissend dass sich nicht alle
bedrohungen der zukunft mit den mitteln
der bundeswehr ein hängen lassen
deshalb brauchen wir eine starke
entwicklungszusammenarbeit
besser
deshalb werden wir uns stark technisch
und gesellschaftlich zb gegen
cyberangriffe und
desinformationskampagne den gegenangriff
auf unsere kritische infrastruktur und
kommunikationswege
und wir werden technologisch auf der
höhe der zeit bleiben
darum ist es mir zum beispiel so wichtig
dass wir die nächste generation von
kampfflugzeugen und panzern gemeinsam
mit europäischen partnern und
insbesondere frankreich hier in europa
bauen diese projekte haben oberste
priorität für uns
bis die neuen flugzeuge einsatzbereit
sind werden wir den eurofighter
gemeinsam weiterentwickeln gut ist auch
dass die verträge zur euro drohne in
dieser woche endlich unterzeichnet
werden konnten
auch die anschaffung der bewaffneten
heron drohne aus israel treiben wir
voran
und für die nukleare teilhabe werden wir
rechtzeitig an modernen ersatz für die
veralteten tornado-jets beschaffen der
eurofighter soll zu electronic warfare
befähigt werden das kampfflugzeug f 35
kommt als trägerflugzeug in betracht
und schließlich meine damen und herren
werden wir mehr tun um unsere eine
sichere energie versorgung unseres
landes zu gewährleisten
eine wichtige maßnahme dazu hat die
bundesregierung bereits auf den weg
gebracht und wir werden um steuern um
steuern um unsere importabhängigkeit von
einzelnen energielieferanten zu
überwinden
die ereignisse der letzten tage und
wochen haben uns doch gezeigt eine
verantwortungsvolle vorausschauende
energiepolitik ist nicht nur
entscheidend für unsere wirtschaft und
unser klima
sondern entscheidend auch für unsere
sicherheit
deshalb gilt je schneller wir den ausbau
erneuerbarer energien vorantreiben desto
besser
und wir sind auf dem richtigen weg wir
wollen als industrieland bis 2045 und 29
mit diesem ziel vor augen werden wir
wichtige entscheidungen treffen müssen
etwa eine kohle und gastgewerbe
aufzubauen wir haben beschlossen die
speichermenge an erdgas über so genannte
long term auction zum 2 milliarden
kubikmeter zu erhöhen zudem werden wir
rückgekoppelt mit der eu zusätzliches
erdgas auf den weltmärkten erwerbung
und schließlich haben wir die
entscheidung getroffen zwei
flüssiggasterminals lng terminals in
brunsbüttel und wilhelmshaven schnell zu
bauen
bundeswirtschaftsminister habe ich
möchte ich für seinen einsatz dabei ganz
ausdrücklich danken
dass das nun kurzfristig notwendig ist
lässt sich mit dem verbinden was
langfristig ohnehin gebraucht wird für
den erfolg der transformation ein lng
terminal in dem wir heute gas ankommen
lassen kann morgen auch grünen
wasserstoff aufnehmen
und natürlich behalten wir bei alldem
die hohen energiepreise im blick
notdienst krieg hat sie zuletzt noch
weiter steigen lassen
deshalb haben wir in dieser woche ein
entlastungspaket vereinbart mit der
abschaffung der eeg umlage noch in
diesem jahr eine erhöhung der
pendlerpauschale um heizkostenzuschuss
für geringverdiener zuschüsse für
familien und steuerlichen entlastung die
bundesregierung wird das schnell auf den
weg bringen
unsere botschaft ist klar wir lassen die
bürgerinnen und bürger und die
unternehmen in dieser lage nicht allein
meine damen und herren die zeitenwende
trifft nicht nur unser land sie trifft
ganz europa und auch darin stecken
herausforderung und chance zugleich
die herausforderung besteht darin die
souveränität der europäischen union
nachhaltig und dauerhaft zu stärken die
chance liegt darin dass wir die
geschlossenheit waren die wir in den
letzten tagen unter beweis gestellt
haben stichwort sanktionspaket
für deutschland und für alle anderen
mitgliedsländer der eu heißt das nicht
bloß zu fragen was man für das eigene
land in brüssel heraushören kann sondern
zu fragen was ist das beste was ist die
beste entscheidung für die union
europa ist unser handlungsrahmen nur
wenn wir das begreifen werden wir vor
den herausforderungen unserer zeit
bestehen
und damit wir nicht beim fünften und
letzten punkt
putins krieg bedeutet eine zäsur auch
für unsere außenpolitik
so viel diplomatie wie möglich ohne naiv
zu sein dieser anspruch
nicht naiv zu sein das bedeutet aber
auch kein reden um des redens linz für
echten dialog braucht es die
bereitschaft dazu auf beiden seiten
daran mangelt es auf seiten putins ganz
offensichtlich und das nicht erst in den
letzten tagen und wochen
dh dass für die zukunft
wir werden uns gespräch mit russland
nicht verweigern auch in dieser extremen
lage ist es die aufgabe der diplomatie
gesprächskanäle offen zu halten
alles andere halte ich für
unverantwortlich
meine damen und herren wir wissen wofür
wir einstehen auch angesichts unserer
eigenen geschichte wir stehen ein für
den frieden in europa
wir werden uns nie abfinden mit gewalt
als mittel der politik wir werden uns
immer stark machen wird es die
friedliche lösung von konflikten und wir
werden nicht ruhen bis der frieden in
europa gesichert ist
und dabei stehen wir nicht allein
sondern zusammen mit unseren freunden
und partnern in europa und weltweit
unsere größte stärke sind unsere
bündnisse und allianzen ihnen verdanken
wir das große glück dass unser land seit
über 30 jahren genießt in einem
vereinten land zu leben in wohlstand und
frieden mit unseren nachbarn
wenn wir wollen dass diese letzten 30
jahre keine historische ausnahme bleiben
dann müssen wir alles tun für den
zusammenhalt der europäischen union für
die stärke der nato für noch engere
beziehungen zu unseren freunden partnern
und gleichgesinnten weltweit ich bin
voller zuversicht dass uns das gelingt
denn selten waren wir und unsere partner
so entschlossen und so geschlossen
uns eint in diesen tagen wir wissen um
die stärke freier demokratie wir wissen
was von einem breiten gesellschaftlichen
und politischen konsens getragen wird
das hat bestand auch in dieser
zeitenwende und darüber hinaus
und deshalb danke ich ihnen und allen
fraktionen dieses hauses die den
russischen überfall auf die ukraine
entschieden als das verurteilt haben was
er ist ein durch nichts zu
rechtfertigender angriff auf ein
unabhängiges land auf die
friedensordnung in europa und in der
welt der heutige entschließungsantrag
bringt das klar zum ausdruck
ich danke allen die in diesen tagen
zeichen setzen gegen putins krieg und
die sich hier in berlin und anderswo zu
friedlichen kundgebung versammeln
und ich danke allen die in diesen zeiten
mit uns einstehen für ein freies und
offenes gerechtes und friedliches europa
wir werden es verteidigen
100 milliarden euro zusätzlich für die
bundeswehr deshalb so olaf scholz eben
gerade in seiner regierungserklärung
angekündigt denn vladimir putin gefährde
die sicherheit europas bei uns jetzt im
studio bild live chef claus strunz klaus
deutschland hat zu spät reagiert da sind
sich ganz viele einig wie hat jetzt
diese erklärung auf dich gesagt ich
glaube in wahrheit weiß dass auch olaf
scholz der ja dann aber viele stränge
zusammen führen muss und das was wir
jetzt gehört erlebt haben zum teil manja
gebannt zugehört ist ein historischer
wendepunkt in der deutschen
nachkriegspolitik nicht mehr aber auch
eben nicht weniger ein ganz
entscheidender impuls ein
sozialdemokratischer kanzler hält eine
aufrüstung rede das muss man sich erst
mal sozusagen im gesamten
geschichtlichen kontext frauen führen
die bundeswehr wird endlich mit einem
sondervermögen von 100 milliarden euro
und die lage versetzt oder soll in die
lage versetzt werden wer fähig zu sein
das kommt
spät aber vielleicht noch nicht zu spät